my name is a he's and I was a former
Hollywood assistant
hi I'm Rachel I'm a former Hollywood
assistant hi my name is Matt and I am a
former Hollywood assistant and I'm about
to reveal one Horror Story and my heart
story is from my first job out of
college and I'm gonna tell you a horror
story I worked at a company that had a
variety type show there was one slip who
he had come in at my last job that I was
like super excited look I grew up
watching this woman like I loved
everything she did I loved her as a
person they were on social media what I
loved everything she stood for look she
was a pioneer in her industry she came
on she did the segment I thought she
killed it like she was super funny super
personable like went with the flow and
it was like one of those things that
even like validated me even more because
I was actually afraid that like she
wasn't gonna live up to who I thought
she was I came in the morning that the
segment went live and the guy but I
watched and I'm like and I was like yep
still as funny as I remember great and
like I went to a comment section I'm no
stranger to like derogatory terms and
like having them been to having them be
talked about in the abstract every
single comment was calling her all of
these derogatory terms for brown and
black women saying that she's like the
scum of the earth saying that they were
gonna like do things to her I've never
seen so much malice and like disgust and
like one concise section her team
reached out and was like hey like can
you do something like it's hard that all
these comments are like public-facing
like it's like can you like disable them
like can you do something like let
people know that it's not okay to say
and the entire time like Farrah like
well we don't want to like tell our fans
that they're wrong we don't want to make
our fans upset you using any form of
derogatory term is wrong there's no way
shape or form you can justify that this
is what they're saying about this
esteemed woman who is on camera who like
is recognizable as what do they think
about people who look like me and like
what does it mean that look I'm working
for a company that
a fanbase that collectively thinks these
things I think seeing that does the
knife a bit deeper it wasn't just like
these fans were awful it was like my
bosses were also awful
I took that as a learning experience I'm
like you know I'm never gonna work
somewhere that's gonna make me
compromise my moral values and that's
gonna make me like come into work and
yet I don't want to work for people
whose audience is against everything
that I am as a human being I had one
boss who was usually very lovely but
largely got what she wanted and when she
didn't get what she wanted she got a
little prickly so there was one day
where she needed a last-minute flight
somewhere I booked the last seat on the
last remaining flight and it just
happened to be a very early flight then
someone else had mentioned that they
were able to find tickets on a different
airline and when I tried to explain that
I don't think that was possible she cut
me off and in a very like Miranda
Priestly Devil Wears Prada moment when I
don't care go fix it and like brushed me
in the face and I went back to my desk
and I emailed HR and I said I would like
to leave this job soon please there was
another moment where she asked me to
print something immediately like the
emails had like print immediately bring
to me immediately and I brought it in
and I handed it to her in a room full of
people and she goes do you want to know
my pet peeve with you and I was just
like okay and she goes so sometimes you
hand me papers that don't have any
paperclip or staple and other people and
I'm not saying I would but other people
would fire you for this and later that
afternoon I printed out something for
her stapled it in all four corners and I
handed it to her and she went you're
such a [ __ ] I love it so we had this I
think it was like meeting place or Adobe
Connect it was some sort of conferencing
system and my new boss was holding like
Oh Us sales worldwide meeting and so you
had to sign in for this one it wasn't
dialing in or anything like that and I
was so cocky and it was like I can't
live have this job can we've been
working in the city I was so excited and
I just like kept pushing the envelope
I signed into this worldwide conference
as its kesha [ __ ] and I did it in all
caps with the money sign because I
thought that I had pressed something
that like my name wasn't going to show
up like I typed in my regular name and
then it was like thought it said like
nickname but it was awesome it was
really like name to appear on the screen
and so in all capitals and I was late so
in all capitals about ten minutes into
this meeting there's just a notification
on the screen that says it's Kesha
[ __ ] has entered the meeting granted
we're in a very small office in New York
and you know what they knew like there
could be no other person because
everybody there was like 25 years older
than me and they were like no one has
ever done that on a conference call
before and so my first initial reaction
was like oh my god get out of the call
but if I got out of the call it was
gonna say that I had just left so I was
like alright maybe I'll just stay on and
nobody will know and then all of a
sudden they come walking by my desk and
so I basically closed the meeting off my
screen muted my computer and just
pretended I had never even signed on I
was like actually they came over and
they were like Rachel did you like sign
into this meeting like we saw something
weird come up screen I was like no I'm
so slams I just got like an order in
from Staples I have to like organize all
this stuff can you just help you just
tell him I'm really sorry like I think I
even said like don't tell me I didn't
join he's gonna be so mad at me and they
were like oh okay like no problem at all
whatsoever it turns out my boss like
goes and asked me it like did you do
this I'm like no and he goes ok he was
like I'm just gonna go to IT then and
see who it was because it was really
inappropriate so I had to tell him and
he was not pumped about it but he was
like hey listen duh can't do that I just
completely embarrassed myself so my name
is actually Rachel it's not it's Ke$ha
[ __ ] but I wish it was and that's my
horror story
[Music]